That's cutters you wanted to know by vitamin D level, and it was 79.6. I currently am taking
380K avail, so the 80K that comes with 80K avail has 5,000 IUs of vitamin D, vitamin D,
measure to the international units. So 15,000 IUs, and remember the vitamin D is a fat soluble
vitamin. So, you know, if you're not dealing with low vitamin D levels, you don't necessarily
even need to take vitamin D on a daily basis. It will store your body. So what are the
proper levels of vitamin D? Well, depending on what lab runs your tests, because different
labs have the right to say what is a normal range or not. So most labs will say
30 to 80 is a normal range of vitamin D, 30 to 80 desolators per milliliter. And it's
but as I wrote in my book, and we've talked about this before, I really want my patients to have
a vitamin D level of 15 to 150. So if you're over, if you're at like one, if you were, if you said
your vitamin D level was 179, and I would say, okay, dropped out to one a day or take, you know,
one every other day, is that too high? Is there a danger of getting too high of vitamin D?
Well, what do you think is you could be able to balance, right? But even somebody who has, you know,
vitamin D at 179, I still don't think that's really too high. I still, I don't think you necessarily
don't need to be taking as much vitamin D exogenously if you're at 179. But if you're at 179, I'd keep
taking three. If it takes three, 80K complete, which is 15,000 I use a day to get you at seven,
to get you at 79, then you really need to be taking three. You know, is somebody else had a last week
had a vitamin D of 45 or something like that? Is that too low? Well, no, technically, that's totally
within range, except if you're trying to, you know, stimulate an immune response and vitamin D can,
the beauty of vitamin D is it's immune modulating and it'll protect you from an auto immune response
and it'll help your body fire a response against a cancer or a pathogen. So higher, higher is better,
for sure. So if I was at, if I tested by vitamin D and I was 40, I would start taking 80K
or a vitamin D up 10 to 15,000 I use that I'd get it rechecked again. You really wanted above 50,
that's a goal.